[Music]
guess what your stupid bell ends we made
it
did i just demonetize this video yeah
don't give a [ __ ]
we [ __ ] made it
52 weeks back to back
to back i feel like drake didn't didn't
miss [ __ ] bro didn't miss
a [ __ ] week who's laughing no mob
who's laughing now [ __ ]
no in all seriousness this would happen
without you guys
so this is this is a milestone for us
bro
bro we never thought we were actually
going to get here so we'll probably
spend the next probably spend the next
40 minutes
reminiscing on [ __ ] and then i'm joking
obviously but
um and then after that we will uh
do some funny [ __ ] and for those that
haven't followed us in the past and just
have listened to like the most recent
episodes
this is episode 52 meaning we've been
doing this for exactly
one year happy birthday sng happy
birthday sng
happy [ __ ] birthday to the fans as
well happy birthday
it's crazy spud
we made it right we made it i love you
bro i love you too bro um you made it
it's been an eventful year
it has been it's flown by yeah man and
you've spoken about
[ __ ] loads of [ __ ] bear [ __ ] loads of
[ __ ] and people were just joining us if
this is your first episode welcome
welcome um and yeah man we
this is the thing right so i don't i'm
i'm not prideful like i don't have an
ego so i don't care about sharing
our numbers and stuff like that like
we make so let's say we we get about
somewhere in the region of like 2 000
audio downloads a day
so what's that like 14 000 a week
uh and probably like three thousand well
the channel as a whole the channel
as a whole gets about uh
fifty
about 15 actually you're about about the
same actually youtube channel gets about
15 000 views
a week okay um so let's call it 30 000.
collectively yeah 30 000 view stroke
listens a week
which is good it's great she's good
in the beginning there was man
in the beginning bruv human don't get it
we got
[ __ ] all you men don't get it when we
started this
we had about two listeners oh my days
and one of them was me
and the other was me yeah yeah yeah we
had [ __ ] all going on no one gave a [ __ ]
no one wanted to listen that no one in
instagram i remember when
it took us about a month and a half to i
think get to
20 instagram subscribe
followers really 20. i don't recall
20 instagram followers
took about a month over a month maybe
even longer than that
and it was such a slow burn and i i
remember thinking
[ __ ] hell [ __ ] hell [ __ ] hell
like this is gonna take
like not necessarily not even about what
it's gonna take in terms of time wise
but i'm thinking like maybe it's [ __ ]
maybe it's it's [ __ ] and that's why no
one's [ __ ] with it yeah
and then we move forward in the months
and even
what five six months in
i think before corona hit before corona
here
five six months yeah but call it six
months so september to march so just
before corona
we'd made it to 65 youtube subscribers i
remember the day i was in the gym
65 because we'd shot up from 60 to 65 in
a day
and i was like oh oh god oh my god five
subs overnight are you [ __ ] crazy
five subscribers overnight like we're
moving and shaking shaking
fast forward another six months probably
get
five subscribers every
half an hour hour if that yeah
and uh 30 000 downloads so
stroke views or whatever a week
and uh yeah it's only gonna get better
it's only going to get bigger and better
and it only is only down
to awesome people
who take the time out of their day to to
show their attention to us for no
[ __ ] reason for what reason i do not
know
but it's all about the shares man
yeah so these guys are are happy to
share
and that's super awesome like we see
yeah we see like how many shares and
stuff we get and stuff like that and
it's just like wow like
people are taking the time not only do
they like it but they're like
they want to share the love patreon
again
we started patreon what four months in
five months in
and um yeah at first
i had faith if we zero expectations
let's be honest i had zero expectation
anyone's gonna pay
you obliged me you let me do it anyway
which i'm grateful for
and you were like cool just do eating
obviously you didn't necessarily you
were nice enough to not tell me that you
had no faith whatsoever which was cool
and here we are now we have money in the
bank every month
we do thanks to you guys thanks to you
guys so much appreciated
super good quote i was watching will
smith's instagram muslim is literally
the king of instagram his instagram is
he's been on instagram for five minutes
and he's literally
bodied it um he's completed instagram
but he posted someone's quote the other
day
which hit me straight in my chest and it
was
if you can't get over the fear just do
it scared
yeah i saw that i saw that big boy quote
big but i don't know whose quote it was
originally i think he did
quite the person in there but um
if you can't get over the fear just do
it scared
and that's the biggest takeaway that i
would like to say with uh
the podcast stuff is like you can have
all the tools in the world
yeah but fear is always we spoke about
before getting started on something is
always the biggest
hurdle of course just taking the leap
and just thinking [ __ ] it just do it man
like
the people always people
when you when you message us you may
think you're the only one but you never
are
trust me everyone's unique and wonderful
but your fears are everyone else's fears
and they're all just material fears
like everyone feels like
everyone feels like the thing that's
holding them back
is individual to them yeah because it
helps them justify their fear yeah but
you have the same fears everyone else
has
but someone managed to do it we managed
to do it
i was scared as [ __ ] i said before i had
the equipment about a month before we
ever did it
you said because i'm [ __ ] myself
yeah um but here we are man and now
it's our part-time job it actually
is it's our second job now it actually
is it's our second job now
um so it will be our first job in a few
months as well so
touchwood touchwood so yeah um
just do it scared man [ __ ] it who cares
just do it
take that leap of faith anything you
want to do in life mom and it's yeah
this doesn't just
apply to podcasting in anything you want
like
it's just it applies to anything in life
and like i said like
you might message us hoping for the
answer like people message us
sometimes and they're just like i really
want to start my podcast
or and i just want some advice or can
you give me any hits like
i'm really worried about this or that
and
again like you think that is just you
that feels that way but that's the tenth
message we've received
exactly with the exact same [ __ ] in it
so don't worry
just do it anyway the only ones just do
it anyway and if you don't like it suck
it off like
things in life just don't come handed to
you and you have to just change
sometimes they do when you're lucky
yeah bro nine times out of ten you have
to chase your ship man you have to you
have to chase your [ __ ] and
it's one thing this year's taught me
is that people always used to say oh um
success is when
luck meets preparation okay success is
when
luck meets preparation and every success
we've had this year
has only come from the work that we've
done
already yeah so i was talking to
uh someone the other day
uh one of our friends the other day and
they mentioned that
uh glamour mag feature yes
and i was like yeah it's all good like
obviously you know i mean i don't like
to boast or anything like that and i was
like yes nice and
uh and he was like yeah man he's good
it's good yeah and i was like yeah
yeah it is good and um i said but
obviously when you get down to it the
realist the
reality is is just like um
one of the editors or writers or
whatever happens to work for that
company yeah and happens to listen to us
at the same time
so that's we're just lucky we're lucky
yeah and he was like cool yeah you may
have been lucky
but if you'd only had two [ __ ] episodes
before that and you're only on episode
three now
you think you think you just because
they listen like they you're gonna
they're gonna
put you in the magazine like they're not
going to they only put you in there
because
you've got enough you've got a catalogue
you've got a catalogue yeah and if you
didn't have that if you would have given
up or you kept skipping weeks and all
that stuff if you
hadn't been working the entire time
regardless if they're a listener or not
yeah
regardless if they love it or not if you
didn't have the hard work put in and all
the catalogue and stuff like that then
it still wouldn't have happened
yeah there's this that reminds me of
something i saw on twitter there was
someone painting something
i can't remember what it was but maybe
people have seen it before
um it was amazing it was [ __ ] amazing
and he painted like a
like a gold quiff line or something like
that was like the final detail of
something people were talking about that
and someone quoted you that you're
paying me for the hardship
of me learning how to do that you're not
paying me for the 15 minutes of me
painting these paintings you know what i
mean
so that's why i'm charging x amount of
money because you're paying me for what
i've put in
you're paying for all the training very
good point pay me for all the training
i've put in you're not paying me for
this piece you pay you're paying me for
the 15 years of hard work it took me to
be able to do this to do that in an
instant
yeah [ __ ] i'd never thought about that
it's
exactly right man so it's consistency
guys
consistency [ __ ] anything over you just
keep doing [ __ ]
and just keep doing it you get better
and better and better and better
anything it can apply to your diet it
can apply to your do you jimin and give
apply to you [ __ ] learning a new
language it can apply to you playing
games whatever
do it week in week out day in day out
whichever your routine is
and trust me you will see results it's
it's a fact
it's a fact it is a fact it's a fact
it's not it's not it's not
it's not fiction it's an actual fact it
is a fact um
and we've had some super motivating
conversations today 100
uh and this week and this year and
everything and we're just super grateful
for everyone
we're grateful for some of the messages
we receive man some of them are just
like
jesus wow they're crazy some of the
messages we receive
like what we mean to them we listen to
you every week
i don't want to bait anything out
obviously because it's personal but it's
just like
you have no idea sometimes when
especially me obviously because we don't
live together
so when i read stuff it could be
different when he reads stuff and my
emotion might be different to his
emotion blah blah blah
so there are times when i read some of
the messages that we get sent either to
our personal dms
or our shits and gigs instagram dms or
even twitter
and i'm like wow we're just
talking me and james are just talking as
boys as best friends
the camera's on and we're just having a
[ __ ] laugh but the fact that
you guys tune in listen week in week out
and
it means something more to you than what
it is to us
in that essence yeah it's like like
it's mind-blowing to men and for people
like that we
we actually thank you up i personally
thank you so much for stuff like that
because
the mess those kind of messages inspire
me
to keep it going well yeah i don't think
i don't think
yeah yeah like yeah i would say
it means it's surprising okay it works
out son
deep breath it's surpri what's
surprising to me
is not that it means more to them than
it does to us
is that my conversation with you
yeah my best friend means as much to
someone who's never met us
as it does to me having the conversation
context i like that yeah i like that
yeah
that's what's surprising and also for
viewers listeners that have listened
from the jump or like listening to like
a healthy amount let's say 20 episodes
30 episodes
you guys in your in your right minds you
feel like you know us now
i need to do and you do that's the scary
part it's it's scary but it's also
i don't know i don't know the word to
describe the feeling it's
a crazy emotion because you actually
feel like you know us
and if it wasn't for the consistency if
it wasn't for the week in week out every
monday i was putting the episodes on
us [ __ ] struggling and striving to
make sure we're getting this done
everything he wouldn't have that same
gratification or that same feeling
towards us
when you do watch or if you do listen to
it because we've put in that work
yes it's all for you guys everyone's
super helpful
every time someone comments or messages
and it's like ah
like say whatever nice thing they want
to say but then when they finish it and
they're just like i'm waiting for the
day you guys quit your jobs
the fact that that actually is important
to someone who's never met me in my
entire life
never will probably never will you know
what i mean
it's gives me chills sometimes he gives
me chills it's [ __ ] nuts but it's um
it's mine yeah man from there someone uh
so someone
asked us to talk about this is a good
one what
are our hopes or our plans for the next
year so
one year in what's the plans for year
two
so for you you go first and then i'll
also so plans for year two
so like by the tail end of the second
year so week
episode 104 episode 104 yeah so by
by end of episode 104 when episode 104
is released
i want to be or i want us to be in a
place where
we have the power to quit our jobs but
we're in a balance of whether
we can do it either today or let's wait
a bit
let's say we make a month or so when we
know everything's solidified
because in a year's time i feel like
we would have because of the hardship we
put this year
in this year we would have hit a
momentum where
we're inevitably not going to be able to
be stopped yeah yeah
do you know what i mean yeah yeah and i
feel like because of the
because of how vast our fan base is and
we're not just
our fan base isn't just based in the uk
it's not just segregated to women it's
not just segregated to men
how vast our fan base is the bigger and
bigger our podcast grows the more and
more different eclectic people that are
going to listen to it
and that in turn is just gonna grow our
podcast and by that time that grows our
podcast whether it be on youtube whether
it be on
get them buying our merch whether
they're signing up to patreon youtube
alone or spotify alone
that gives us the equity to
move forward and do what we truly love
which is
sit here flick the camera on and chat
absolute [ __ ]
do you know what i mean yeah man express
yourself express ourselves have a laugh
talk about what's on our mind be
unapologetic and just try
our hardest to be ourselves
and um that's what's important to me so
yeah
this time next year i would like us i'll
talk more about kind of like small
things then
um i would like us obviously depending
on the state of
kovid yeah by this time next year i
would have liked us to
booked in some meet and greets oh
booked into meet and greets so yeah
obviously yeah we'll get that sorted
um let's start off in the uk and then
branch out from there
um i will come in yeah wait australia
what come in
usa california california
um yeah so
i would like that for one uh so yeah
it'd be nice to start meeting some
more people so i'm putting some faces to
the names if you
yeah yeah hundred percent yeah yeah
because you've got like i said we've got
a collective fan base and a lot of the
fans
are consistent as well and they're from
completely different countries so some
from sweden some from norway some from
um usa some from australia australia
australia so if we actually
go out and get to see them as people
it's cool man
it will be incredible um so meet and
greets in the kind of live shows i would
like us to get done in the next 12
months
um i would like obviously for us to quit
um our jobs and um
i was gonna say something what was it
what was it that i wanted to do
um i don't know man i would like just to
just
keep our integrity where it's at i would
like us to be
an example for something in the next 12
months
i've been trying obviously i've been
pushing this for obviously this 12
months
but it's it's becoming more prominent
as the days go on that it's important
for us
and especially after the conversation we
just had yeah um
with a lovely person it's important for
us
to continue to try and be as honest
as we can yeah in this kind of pc world
that we live in and the point about what
you said
me uh yeah a minute ago in terms of um
[ __ ] what did you just say um
just in terms of wait what the [ __ ] am i
even talking about what did you just say
i don't know frank do you ever have that
when your mind just goes completely
blank yeah mid-sentence yes but the mind
is a mysterious thing
i was able to do that i was present
beyond i knew what i was talking about
and all of a sudden it's gone
it was a distraction i don't know it's
like i didn't get distracted by anything
it was weird anyway so what i was trying
to say is yeah
back to the point in hand [ __ ] how so
it's important for us to be
who we are yes at what you said about
people knowing us
people knowing us so it's very easy
to take a lot of the stuff that we say
use it out of context yeah and
paint us in a bad light that's easy it's
easy to do for anyone for anyone
anywhere anyone to do
yeah if you if you've never seen any of
our episodes or anything and you just
clicked on youtube fast forward it to
midway you don't know anything about us
and then catch
us saying half the stuff we say you're
probably like [ __ ] these guys
[ __ ] these guys they're pricks yeah the
good thing about what we do
and the art of long excuse me long-form
conversation
is that you get the opportunity to know
people
understand their intent understand their
morals understand
who they are as a person so you don't
have to subscribe to being
part of a culture that chastises people
for saying certain things
yeah when you take it out of context
because context is important
context is important in everything you
can say the same word in three different
tones of voice and it means three
different things
so just taking something someone said
and using it as a weapon against them
out of context
is just so prevalent today
and i [ __ ] hate it so
i would like in the next 12 months us to
keep our integrity where it's at
100 and make the sacrifices that will we
make
to make the sacrifices that we make to
continue to do that
um like for example like people this is
something like we don't speak about like
people
never noticed at the beginning of the
video like youtube
basically demonetizes us entirely
entirely before what we say
so we don't really get paid for youtube
at all we should be making way more on
youtube than we do
but they did not demonetize us pretty
much every week
because of the stuff we say and yes
there are little kind of workarounds
that you can try and do but just like
we're not really gonna budge on what we
say and how we say it and stuff like
that here we are and who we are for the
sake of money
and i would like that to continue
obviously like i said it's easy to say
now
yeah because we're not it's not a
million [ __ ] pounds that we're yeah
yeah
yeah or whatever i would like to still
be in that position a year from now
and the year after that and the year
after that and just be like no just no
i'm not willing to i'm not willing to
change so um
yeah i would like that um and yeah yeah
the year i would just like it to be more
funny [ __ ] ah that's what i was gonna
[ __ ] say
guests guests
so thanks to you lovely uh
patrons and for the little bit of money
that youtube does give us
and people who buy the merch and all
that stuff uh we managed to get loads of
money together and
spend a little bit on some new equipment
so we've got a new microphone
and all that jazz so in the year coming
now
we will start having some guests on
yes we know you want [ __ ] bella
everyone knows
everyone's been saying get bellow on the
podcast we know um
so yeah we're going to be having guests
on and um
it's not going to be all the time
because the show is going to stay the
same yeah i've listened to podcast in
the past where it's just been two guys
yeah and then they start putting guests
on and it ruins the whole
thing because i'm not there for that
person it's a nice change
yeah yeah it's a nice change sometimes
yeah but the show has to keep its
integrity
so but now and again we're gonna have
guests on um
and they're just gonna be friends of
ours they're just gonna people we enjoy
spending time with yeah it's not gonna
necessarily be
anyone that's gonna help us on a
cross-platform sense
we don't even like them so we're just
doing it to get more views it's not
never going to be anything like that
people that you guys most likely won't
know um
but it'll be fun it'll be fun to listen
to anyway um
so yeah i think without any further ado
let's actually say some funny [ __ ]
that was emotional i'm not gonna lie i
don't know how long that was probably 15
minutes or whatever
it was cool it's it's um it was an
eye-opener and
thank you again anyway
so first request of the day in terms to
speak of
is quick quickly before that fun fact of
the day
um oh yeah fun fact go on fun fact of
the day
there was a there's a guy called william
morrison
morrison million morrison quote me if
i'm wrong
um he's a dentist he invented
candy floss aka cotton candy okay so he
did that
so his this was back in the day yeah he
did that
so he's colleagues and peers can have
more business
really isn't that a wild concept so
cotton candy or candy floss whichever
country you're on
you're in was invented by a dentist so
kids
can continuously eat sweets so they can
[ __ ] up their teeth
so dentists can get paid consistently
wow mind blown right wow
that's crazy that's very crazy did he
not just set his pattern and then
[ __ ]
live off the royalties of candy floss
forever actually [ __ ] being a dentist
i'm rich's tits um that is interesting
what's snakey [ __ ] it's crazy right
i bet their dentistry was [ __ ] back in
the day they didn't have veneers back
then
what are they even doing to sort his
teeth out brav who knows what evil [ __ ]
but yeah that's the fun fact today that
is interesting i'm loving fun facts
right i hope you guys are too so we got
fan request and we tried our best today
we thought we're just going to do final
requests
mostly um so
first one how to avoid a fuckboy
now as i said to the person who
requested this topic
i empower [ __ ] boys i don't want to
i don't want to ruin the game for them
we can't ruin the game boys need [ __ ]
too
the game is the game is the game and
there are no cheat codes to the game
that needs to be understood first and
foremost and i think the
easiest answer to that question is like
how to avoid [ __ ] boys
is it's easy because every guy can
every girl could spot a [ __ ] boy from a
mile away every guy every girl can
i feel like i feel like almost every
girl got because they
they know the flags they see them they
still
you're going to see where you're going
with this wanna go there you flipped me
you flipped me mid-sentence i was about
to be like i disagree 100
you flipped me you still want to go
there because like i said
i've i've seen it happen not to me
personally but i've seen it happen like
i don't wanna i don't i can't out people
out people
that's the thing i can't help people
because it is then the game is the game
but i've just seen it happen red flags
galore but you will still go there
because
why it's fun that's the thing
you say you want to avoid a [ __ ] boy but
[ __ ] boys sometimes give you life they
give you something
non [ __ ] boys are boring
non [ __ ] boys are boring it boils down
to what we said prior
myself included boring it boils down to
what we said
a few episodes ago about no one just
wants
rough anal sex or you don't want
missionary
sex all the time you want a mix and
match you do want to make so you're
always gonna
have being a you're always gonna have a
stage of your life where
a fuckboy might be entertaining you and
you might be
in that frame of mind where you're going
to entertain that [ __ ] for you as well
yeah man
obviously the longevity of that
relationship quote unquote isn't going
to last long because you know that's not
what you're there for
but at that time in at that time of your
life is something you may have needed
and it could help you get over stuff
yeah just assume
no just assume anyone who's boring
is not a fuckboy and anyone who's
awesome
is a fuckboy now you're that doesn't
paint a picture for everyone yeah some
awesome people
also aren't [ __ ] boys yeah but for the
general sense of it
if you're too awesome you're probably a
[ __ ] boy because guess what
you're not the only one who thinks he's
awesome true other hosts think he's
awesome too
and guys aren't just out here turning
down [ __ ] left right and center
come on now [ __ ] controls the world oh
[ __ ]
i'm so sick of tired of it and it is it
does control the world
and it's ridiculous but yes [ __ ] boys
are out there
that a lot of time they make themselves
known sometimes they
hide in the tall grass but they always
give you red flags
always when he's got the chit chat when
you're out for cocktails and he's got
the chin wag
he's a [ __ ] boy who's he been talking to
where'd he get this practice
these are questions you need to be
asking yourself
when he works in accounting he's
probably not a [ __ ] boy he doesn't have
the time to be dating
he doesn't have the time to be a [ __ ]
but he hasn't got the luxury to be a
[ __ ] damn
when his hairline's receding he's
probably not a fighter
he's stressed he hasn't got time no one
wants to [ __ ] him and he doesn't want to
[ __ ] them those are the guys you want to
settle down with if you want to avoid
[ __ ] boys
you're probably thinking you don't want
to i don't want a boring guy i don't
want a guy over a seating hairline i
don't want jeff from accounting
tough you love saying jeff from account
yeah from a cat everyone knows one jeff
from accounting
i don't want jeff from accounting that's
my man i want
hey i want to latin dance with jorge to
give him that dangler day
i want someone who's gonna [ __ ] throw
me about i want someone who's gonna pull
my hair that's why i want someone who's
muscular and tall and handsome and
oiled beard and all that stuff guess
what
[ __ ] boy
so you answered your own question fam
this is happy yeah it's not the answer
you wanted
but that's what it is that's what you're
going to get that's what it is jeffrey
is not a fuckboy to paint a picture on
why i said
obviously everyone knows [ __ ] runs the
world anyway but to paint the picture
and to give a context as to why i said
that
yeah and an example rather i was talking
to someone
um this was a few i was doing something
recently but this situation happened a
few years ago if that makes sense
she had recently become single
and there's this there's been a guy that
she's
they've there's been a guy that's
fancied her for a while yeah
and they she could obviously tell he
wanted to [ __ ] her
and she saw that in him and she not
i wouldn't say she fancied him but they
had a flirtatious kind of
situation yeah yeah but nothing ever
occurred obviously because she she was
she was taken yes so
there was a point where she was recently
single
she saw this guy in a club and she said
to herself
i'm gonna [ __ ] this guy tonight and the
first thing she said when she saw him
was hi i'm single and that was all it
took that's all
it took she had the
i don't know the word i'm looking for
she had the
oh what's the word i'm looking for she
just had the thought of
i'm [ __ ] this guy today if she has
that thought there's nothing that's
changing that
because if i say to what if i say to
myself i see you go oh i'm [ __ ] this
girl tonight
i'm probably not of course i'm not i'm
not [ __ ] this girl tonight
i'm not [ __ ] anyone tonight fam her
ears will prick up like a dog even if
i've said it in my head
is a pickle like a dog and sugar like
him no no i can
smell the thirst on this guy's breath
she just said
to herself i'm [ __ ] this guy tonight
and she walled up to her and said
he was walked passing through they were
in the shops by the way shubs is a club
and she stopped in front of her said hi
i'm
single apparently man was moving mad say
let's go
now let's go now she was like nah
wait i'll say till when
no wait man said he she said man was
prancing around the shrubs like when are
we going
man said she said man drove like his
life depended on it
like his life depending on it [ __ ] a sec
c that is sec c
what i'd give for that situation no one
could tell me that
hi i'm single ah
especially if it's if it's a thing that
you've been
quote unquote fantasizing about for for
a while
yes yes yes yes elasticate
fam ah
i'd have to patent viagra oh could you i
have to play invite
stop it i'm making this a life changing
experience
this will be a life changing experience
some girls some girls bruv
when they're willing to shoot their shot
and they do it to that caliber to that
caliber
that's impressive we obviously spoke
about shooting your shot
in a few episodes ago but that
that's a three pointer fam that's a
buzzer half court
bang that's a buzzer b that's a buzzer
beater
[ __ ] jesus christ i'd feel so
excited but yet scared oh yeah because
the power is
it's out of your hands now it's not my
choice it's such a power play it was
and from when she said well from when my
man asked oh let's go and she said now
wait oh i'll be sitting there twiddling
my thumbs i'll be holding her purse in
the corner looks like
checking the time frame fam
oh my god it's very sexy so hard it's
crazy can you think of a time
where you've approached a thing with
serious bravado yeah
and it's paid off
i'll wait i'm playing eyes definitely
not happening with me
[Music]
i want to say yes but i'm trying to
think of a specific example
because it clearly doesn't happen often
this is the thing it actually
doesn't um
okay it didn't necessarily pay off
because i didn't act on it
but i'll give you the story anyway so i
was
i was at a bar one time i was at albert
schloss um whoever lives in manchester
knows obviously where average loss is
i was in auburn um and this wasn't
recently by the way
and i was there with like work
colleagues in red setter
and you know as you do as we always do
when we're in a club or a bar we scan
the room
so i scanned the room the first time i
caught an eye
of a female she looked good and i'm
assuming she acknowledged i looked good
too because we held eye contact for a
bit
and then i went back to my group of
friends i was like cool and then
i wanted to go toilet but i walked the
long way to see if she was still there
yeah yeah we made eye contact again and
i went to speak to her yeah yeah
see we were just talking talking talking
introduced myself made her laugh red
and i said okay i'm gonna go toilet no
the reason i didn't approach her the
first time was because
she was with her girl yeah yeah and i
never liked doing the two like a
two girls one guy yeah i don't like i
mean it needs to be balanced
yeah so i think when i was gonna go
toilet the friend
had probably gone toilet so she was
alone so that was my opinion
speaking to her and i could already tell
off the back it was flowing she was
cute she was nice curly hair nice eye
she had braces as well
about it sometimes there's a sound about
breathing girls have braces and your
smile is a bit oh they're excited about
it i've got nice teeth with braces i
don't know what it is but yes i know
exactly what you're doing but anyway she
was banging she was banging
yeah she was banging anyway um so i said
we spoke
with chin i already knew that if i had
gone the extra mile
i could have potentially either got a
number or like we could have patented
something from there or whatever
but i went toilet and by the time i came
back her friend was there
i still had the same confidence or
whatever and i still spoke to him i
introduced myself to the bredrin
and we couldn't me and this girl
continued our conversation and i asked
her where she lives she said she just
lives outside manchester
et cetera and we i think i
i purposely left it as that because i
know for a fact
i could see what i i thought i could see
that
there wasn't there would have been no
point in me getting a number because
it wasn't a situation where like that
instance where i just gave you i said
i'm gonna [ __ ] this guy tonight
it wasn't that kind of that's not the
vibe i was getting yeah yeah
yeah and it's not like i was out there
looking for that it's just the fact that
i knew for a fact i probably wouldn't be
able to
keep her entertained long enough whilst
we're like doing doing this whatsapp
thing
i would have probably just forgotten it
yeah yeah vice versa she would have
probably
liked stuff as well so i've i didn't
feel like it was necessary to continue
that yeah but
the bravado aspects that was that was
exactly that was an example yeah man
i as you were talking i was trying to
this is how you know i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
as you were talking i was trying to
think for me like is there any time
because i've already explained that
i don't know i don't talk to girls yeah
and i was trying to think of as
anything of that caliber happened to me
where i've like approached the thing and
just been confident that i'm [ __ ]
tonight yeah yeah
and then every single occasion that i
thought of
was the girl doing it to me um was the
girl doing it to me
exactly like the conversation in where
it happened so forwardly
that now i'm thinking was it you no
now i'm thinking wow i think they did
exactly
what you just said that girl did and
they saw me
some of them knew who i was anyway or
one of them knew who i've all
yeah the three occasions i got ahead one
of them already knew who i was
but yeah they'd looked and they were
like i'm [ __ ] tonight
because they came at me with chest
so one of them was
uh do you know this one i think you
know all of them you know of all of them
okay so one of them i tell the stories
right this is
so let's just dive into some fuckboy
chat because people love to hear fuckboy
chat let's i'll talk to you about
james back in the day old school james
when he was a little pathetic little
fuckboy
so james one of the one of the best
versions of you
one of the best versions of you i've
ever seen you are on smoke
there was no there was a period of time
you were untouchable
hands down there was period of time okay
actually before i get into the three
topics actually i don't have
a situation where i knew i was [ __ ] a
specific girl
but exactly what you're talking about
there was a period in time
where i knew when we would roll out on a
monday night hush
i'm having sex i don't even know who
it's gonna be with
but i'm gonna have sex with someone
tonight and i'm pretty sure it happened
every single time it was a weird time
it was like we were we were clubbing in
the upside down
i don't think they actually knew what i
looked like you know i mean
i think it was when drake was on the
come up jeremy
drake was on the come up and they were
like yeah i can see a little yeah yeah
yeah oh that's fine that's probably what
it was because i was
bulletproof i'm not i'm not i don't have
any ego as well like
you should know but i don't like picking
myself up like that but this time was a
weird time
it was it was i was [ __ ] non-stop uh
it was cool it was a good time
it was a very good time but yeah the
three times i had in my head where the
girls actually did it to me
it was one so first one was
deaf mum so
for context listen to this here you
might listen to this
listen to this [ __ ] so i'm on a night
out
this is a very long time ago but i'm on
the night out
and i see this girl she's looking nice
and she's moving even nicer
um oh girl that could move oh bro can
tell a tale
so she um
exactly same thing i'm so sorry to cut
you off i'm so so sorry to cut you off
but i you know this girl i've shown you
her before and there's a girl there's a
go on instagram
that i followed that i've shown you
before that is actually banging
and oh can't dance and she just can't
dance buzzkill buzzkill
let's go man if you're aware that you
can't dance
you have to be self-aware in this world
right you have to be self-aware and not
no one can be good at everything
so if you can't dance
partner in a way that no one ever has to
find out
she has no rhythm but she's
up at you she showed me she's
unbelievably good looking
unbelievably good looking you showed me
before and it it
i feel like it's a waste of beauty
almost it's so unfair to say
it's so far-fetched and unfair to say
yeah yeah yeah but i feel like the two
should come hand in hand
you should have your think so as well as
beauty you'd like to [ __ ] think
anyway sorry to cut you off
there but yeah deaf mum so i'm
people thinking deaf mum yeah you were
that is legit
so
[Music]
i'm out i'm schmoozing i'm having a good
time i'm just
i'm fam i'm in the club and i think i
was with my boy but he had left me at
this point
so he stopped starting down so i'm
thinking in the back of my head i'm
thinking i'm gonna have to get a taxi
home by myself in a bit yeah
so i'm just there just um get money
get money i hope everyone understands
this i hope you guys understand that
reference um
so i'm there with my um get monies and
she clocks me we make eye contact
i do the little embarrassing smile and
turn away
yeah and then she comes up to me i can't
remember for the life of me what she
said
but it was just very upfront and i was
like cool we spoke for a minute
coincidentally the lights turned on and
she said cool i'm going taxi rank are
you coming
and i was thinking i'm going i'm to get
a taxi home anyway so we walked down to
where the taxis were
she jumped in the cab and she was like
share this one
and i was like i don't think we're going
in the same way she was like
we are okay okay
okay jumped in two two talking and now
the sun's coming up so i wasn't in a
good place
if you know me when the sun comes up i
don't want to [ __ ] anyone yeah i want to
go to bed yeah i was like oh god but
anyway
sun's coming up so i'm like cool cool
cool we get back to hers
and i'm like we i'm whispering from as
soon as we get out the taxi now
and she lived a nice area that's all i
remember and then
as we're walking towards the house i'm
trying to be quiet and she's like oh you
don't want you didn't need to be quiet
um my mum's deaf
and i was like that's funny like don't
be me i was like don't be dread yeah
don't be horrible about your mom and
then she was like no she is
and i was like okay fam ignore the
comment
we go at it when we get in yard and
she's
barreling from she's moaning as loud as
anyone ever has
long story short i saw her mum the next
one her mom is legit deaf
legit deaf i know this story is
legit deaf sign language all sorts it's
crazy and i was like oh my god i thought
you were winding me the [ __ ] up
that's i don't know if that's horrible
or not
just aspect just in that that
i don't know i guess when you're growing
up with a deaf mom yeah
you're just used to that she can't hear
yeah yeah
my mom can't hear and that's a
categorical fact and i'm not gonna
be quiet out of politeness or something
that like you're just not relevant to
her yeah to me because i've never
i've met deaf people but i like i don't
i don't have a relationship with any
deputy i've not spent an extended period
of time with a deaf person
yeah yeah yeah so like me trying to be
have manners and be quiet yeah even
though her mom can't hear us
for me i'm just like i feel like i
should still be quiet i don't know i'm
just trying to be polite yeah yeah and
she's like
no yeah she can't hear
i don't know i still don't get to this
day you were probably like eight years
ago i still don't get it
anyway so that was number one she had
came at me with chest
number two um we're talking bird shirt
so i had i had a shirt one time yeah
i was going through this is when i just
i just
got out of my poorest era of my life and
i splurged in top man
and they had like three they had a type
of shirt like a
like a short sleeve shirt and it had
just a bird pattern on it and i must
have bought like three of them in three
different colors
and i'm like cool i'm feeling good yeah
and then um
i walked in the night out one time and
this girl came up to me and she was like
oh
i like your bird shirt and i was like oh
thanks
and she's with her drunk ourselves she's
like bird shirt and then she started
calling me
bird [ __ ] all night any time she walked
past me
yo bird [ __ ] no like shut the [ __ ] up in
here
yo bird [ __ ] what's up and i'm like your
mum in it
so anyway we had this little back and
forth back and forth and foo head knows
this girl fattest arsenitis
fat assassins unparalleled fat assassin
tits
her body was a joke joke a
joke so anyway
um so yeah anyway anyway she we
we have the night and cetera i see a few
different nights out et cetera and then
one night we go to get chicken after a
night out we're all having a good time
she grabs chicken whatever i haven't
spoken to her this night
we're about to leave the chicken shop
she grabs me and she's like are you
coming
and i was like where and she was like
home
i was like gang yes yes you said you
gave your chick the rest of your chicken
to someone yeah
yeah go go
tell donny to floor it let's go
them we got back to hers and she was
like get your clothes off then she got
naked quick
and then she was literally getting close
up there and i'm like huh i felt so
violent i didn't know what to do i
literally wanted to leave at this point
i i i [ __ ] her up peer pressure at
that point you know i mean
she pressured me into at this point i
was like there's no romance here yeah
[Laughter]
where's the romance yeah and i was like
[ __ ] out
and then i was like i get my clothes up
and this one i felt naked you actually
felt naked felt so naked to the point
where i think i covered my dick
even though i'm about to have sex with
this girl i'm here covering my dick like
okay like you're a [ __ ] patient
oh my god so i'm covering up my dick
scared of this girl
anyway we have sex and then i just got
dressed quick
and she was like you're not staying and
i was i was thinking you're the last
person i thought
would ask me to stay but no 100
million no i just like you ran away from
your girlfriend in the other episodes
in year nine i ran away from her i got
my clothes on
and just i i think i remember stretching
my lats like this
and warming up my knees and i was like
cool all right i said later i
ran all the way home i ran all the way
home i didn't skip a beat
and then uh so that was number two
and then number three was
let me get this out
oh [ __ ] and then number three
was um the girl that turned out to be a
stripper
oh my god um what was the first one
again oh
deathman was that one i probably the
only one i wasn't there for definitely
you weren't there for the other two you
were there for yeah yeah so i mean if
you had one a night out
we went into one shady [ __ ] club oh
my god one dirt
it's on top of a chip shop yeah it's in
commentary yeah it's in coventry it's
the dirt it's on top of a [ __ ]
benny's
bennies what an establishment bro it's
on top of a
there's a club on top of a benny's in
coventry i don't know what the club's
called i don't wanna know what the
club's called i don't wanna remember
it's a hole in the wall
such a dive anyway we were there because
we had no other options at this point it
was late
one girl i think i don't even think she
spoke to me in the club
we just made eye contact by the time
we'd left
she was walking behind us on the stairs
on the way down okay
she said i heard her from behind me say
my legs are tired
my girl jumped on my back for a
piggyback
and said let's go i was like go where
and she said back to mine but we haven't
spoken
we haven't spoken i was like jesus
christ
all right same thing tell donny to
florida let's go
firm went back to hers she had a weird
studio apartment
and this is the one where
i called you that's the one i called you
that's the one i called you when you're
talking about this
yeah i'd knot it too early out of panic
or whatever i don't know
the problems was good so i nutted early
and i was like oh dear
it was like foreplay now it was bad like
we hadn't really got into the mix
whatsoever so
got to the toilet splashed my water on
some of my face
tried to get back in the zone and
thought i need to delay saturn so i can
get hard on
if you know the story already sorry to
repeat rank foo had pretended to chat
about anything
the girl doesn't decide to suck me off
and then foo has just here and just bear
dangle the dangs just bear gobble
wobbles
got gawks and um we
hang off the phone and then then that
time i will actually say i gave the
business after that one
business i should have left them a card
business i felt like a gorilla after it
you know what i mean
that time is one of the times where i'm
like you
put it down i want to spud myself i just
i gave a business on that one i know
what ah
[ __ ] i know those type of [ __ ] you're
not like obviously i don't want my
bedrooms to see me [ __ ] someone yeah but
i wish someone saw it
because they would have been like raw
me on i should have given him a card
i gave a business corporate
i love that bam um but yeah anyway that
was that one those are so those are the
three ones that come to mind
where the girls put on girls came at me
with nothing but intent
intent to kill i love that and i obliged
all three times
i love it there have obviously been
occasions where a girl's stepped out i'm
not saying i'm good-looking or anything
but she stepped out of the lane she's
objectively bad looking and she's come
at me with chest
probably thinking that will overcome the
barrier and i was just at a time in my
life where i'm like it's never gonna
happen yeah you spoke about before the
after the phone part you won the big oh
my god the big black girl yeah
she dove she dove at me and you [ __ ]
repelled her like a magnet
nothing is i actually feel i actually
feel bad about her
because she didn't approach me in chest
in a situation where
she had no reason to i was in her
bedroom voluntarily
she had every reason to think that we
were gonna [ __ ]
but there's no way in a million [ __ ]
years i was gonna [ __ ] her
i was someone attracted to her it's
unbearable and i'm sobered up at this
point as well
she leapt at me and i felt with
musculature because i was wearing her
hoodie as well
oh yeah i forgot and it was big on me
so i already felt nah nah i had to ruin
everyone's fun that night
she must have felt so [ __ ] after i
turned that because that is such a way
to turn down something yeah
yeah i just got my [ __ ] and ran out of
the house
[ __ ] but yeah man
one year in one year in hmm
um so talk to me fan requests
let me find the other ones so
[Music]
so many oh my god
i write them down just to
make sure i don't lose them but then we
get so many dms
not to brag so many dm sometimes i'm
just like
where are they where the [ __ ] are they
um someone asked me on youtube once what
my
i can't remember what episode it was
what my um
stretch routine was remember what i was
talking about oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i like to stretch off the
work um i don't really
have a routine if you are listening to
this episode now anyway i don't really
have a necessary routine i just try and
because i have like i said i've got an
anterior pelvic tilt so it's more i
focus more on my back
so i just i've got a roller and i've got
a map
i just always stretch my calves i
stretch my hamstrings i stretch my quads
and i stretch my back that's it i don't
have a specific routine
so if um you just have to work on the
areas that
are good for you i guess that's if you
are listening on if you are watching
this
i thought i'd just hollow back and let
you guys know calm right so this one
is actually very similar to what we were
just talking about from our boy
um yes cool so he's like
um quick question um
james you've mentioned that you used to
be or still quite anxious about
talking to girls et cetera et cetera
after that sixth form situation with um
renting lauren renting lorraine okay now
um
question is how did you and fuhad if it
applies get to the point where you're
comfortably getting kills
and kill street massage kills you know
um just knee deep and puss
uh because the anxiety must have low key
disappeared at some point
um i are either of you low-key worried
or scared of rejection from women
um like now at times
uh or are you past all that uh when did
you get past the point of not caring
um or how do how do or
how did you deal with rejection
um and lastly have either of you
suffered from any anxiety and or
depression in general that's a good one
oh wow um he's asked a lot of questions
so break it down breaking it down
one for me specifically i've spoken
about
being anxious about talking to girls
before so he's asking
in order for us to get to the numbers
that we've obviously got to
when did that disappear if it ever did
um
and if it um and if we got rejected how
did we handle rejection
i think every guy's been rejected so
just yeah
and lastly have either of us ever
suffered from forms of anxiety in the
past
or depression
you got an answer alright cool so for me
unfortunately this is different for you
for me unfortunately to this day
i still don't really
i still i still i still would suffer
from anxiety trying to talk to a girl
nowadays if whatever reason i had to
talk to
a girl now i would still suffer from
some form of anxiety and i was speaking
when i did the live stream the other day
with my boy he asked me about something
similar to this
and i said i think my anxiety or fear of
rejection
stems from not knowing what the girl's
here for
so we're relating it to like a sales job
and stuff like that and when you're
trying to sell something
you already know they're interested in
your product because they came to you
so you don't really have to worry about
rejection that much
because they came to you so with
approaching a complete stranger in a
club or something like that mm-hmm they
didn't come to me
they didn't come before you then come
for me they're minding their own
[ __ ] business so regardless if
they're down for me or not
i am interrupting their life to
sell them myself so that's where my fear
of rejection comes from because they can
give me
there's a million one reasons why they
wouldn't be interested
so it's usually for me once i've
established that first like i said like
the eye contact i've spoken to about
before
anything like that that gives me the
impression oh okay
i know why she's here now yeah i know
she has some form of interest
yeah i have less fear of rejection now
yeah and i would
i would feel more comfortable to go and
talk to someone
um needless to say i still suffer from
the anxiety i still suffer from the fear
of rejection and it would it's still
even to this point this day and age i'm
[ __ ]
nearly 30 years old i still wouldn't
just approach a stranger
okay you're much better than i am yeah
my my story is very very different
purely because
if i stem back to like
obviously you spoke about i had my first
girlfriend in the year eight and then i
was dating someone in year 10
and then obviously i squeezed play-doh
batty and then
when i was in college or sixth form i
had a girlfriend then
when i was in uni i had a girlfriend
then yeah so it's like
i there was never not that there was
never a time where i was just
flamboyantly single
but i'd always managed to find
a partner yeah yeah so
i didn't really need
to warrant a fear of rejection from
females because i wasn't looking for
females because i was in a relationship
yeah yeah i was
i was in quite a few relationships
growing up in life
and then once i graduated
because of my career choice obviously i
work in hospitality
that then boosted my confidence because
in hospitality you have to talk to
strangers every single day like females
love it
i don't know the word i'm looking for
but females just love it they i feel
like they love the fact that
you can command the room okay yeah yeah
the
authority yeah they love that they love
an authoritarian man
yeah and it's not everyone don't get me
wrong but
a majority of people do and the majority
of females do
they find it very sexy they find it
attractive because i feel like it's just
i feel like it's a it's a nurturing
feeling for a female because they know
that a man can provide for them yeah i
feel like that's what what it brings
together yeah yeah yeah yeah so
in that aspect being in that industry or
being in this industry and being a
manager for so long
has tailored me to be flamboyantly
personable to everyone i meet so i can
meet anyone
and not have the intention of wanting to
[ __ ] them but i can hold a conversation
with them yeah yeah you know what i mean
because
yeah everyone's different everyone's
human like the other day we went to
we went to the other time um that bar
camera was called
and i was just randomly talking to
random people i was talking to the dorm
and i was talking you know what i mean
and
it's just it's it's i find it easy
and even talking to the lady that was
serving us drinks i just found it easy
because
i was just having a conversation but i
don't talk to no one it's
it's just how i am so that i'm jealous
of it it's good so
i don't necessarily have a fear of
rejection because it
i won't have a fair rejection obviously
yes i've been rejected before because
every guy has it's
it's normal but the fear isn't there
it's more
it's more i i would more likely get
rejected if i was moving to someone via
social media okay yeah but if i got to
if i spoke
to you on a face-to-face or like
no no let's not even say a club scenario
where you where you have to be like
shouting or like you're dancing like
this other distractions
let's sing in like a bar scenario when
you're talking to someone
not to sound boasty or braggy but i can
make you fall for me
i will swear do you know what i mean
yeah like because because of the way i
talk
because of my career choices in life i
know how to
tailor a conversation because i have to
yeah
and that's the difference in my
experience because
not everyone works in hospitality not
every time my
job makes me who i am and it's
benefiting me outside my job yeah yeah
and that doesn't happen for everyone
yeah if you leave the hospital if you're
a doctor you leave the hospital you're
not going to be a doctor a surgeon at
home
yeah yeah yeah yeah you're just the two
don't relate dave you're just
the the two just relate yeah yeah they
too just don't relate in the hospital
aspect but they do relate for me so
it's it's a weird concept i would say
yes more
rejection from like i would say social
media or like somewhere where you don't
actually get to see me or speak to me
verbally
via whatsapp you know all this kind of
when you have a choice to
either reply to me today or tomorrow
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a huge
difference
yeah yeah it's a huge difference fair
play
um cool man uh he's answered like three
questions
the last one so we've answered the rest
the last one was do you
suffer from any form of like depression
or anything like that or anxiety
i feel like everyone suffers from some
for some form of
anxiety for sure um i don't
suffer from depression i feel like i've
definitely been depressed before i've
said this to you personally before
um some not something i really want to
go into detail about on the pod purely
because it's
very far removed and irrelevant in my
life yeah yeah
and but i feel like i feel like
everybody does need therapy
some form of yeah everybody needs
someone to talk to everybody needs that
one person where
you can say something to them and not
feel judged and not be
judged and just saying it alone
brings a massive relief off your
shoulders and it helps
it helps them traumatic it helps them in
ways you have no idea like it's a
feeling unbeknownst to you yeah
because before me realizing that i was
quote unquote depressed
i didn't know i was i didn't feel like
or no i was the best yeah i mean
maybe you had seen it because you were
in my life at that point
yeah but if i didn't i only thought
about it
years later and when i actually started
to sit down and think about actually go
through
the motions and go through what i went
through like verbally
i sat and i thought oh maybe i actually
was depressed
and it wasn't up until i said it or up
until i ign
not quite quite acknowledging because i
didn't know what has happened at the
time but not until i said it
that i acknowledged it yeah man calm and
it's
i feel like it's something everyone may
suffer from
but they don't know that they suffer
because not everyone's depressed but
everyone has something
they would like to talk about or don't
know they would like to talk about but
if they do talk about it
they have no idea how much weight it
really it would be
that's the thing i'm grateful for you
man uh i'm grateful for
like lewis he's like my day-to-day one
yeah he's like with my day-to-day
struggles
he's like my therapist yeah and then
obviously with like bigger stuff
um sometimes this is like therapy for me
because i just get stuff off my chest
but like yeah i have no reason to bring
because to anyone else yeah
on the podcast yeah you don't need a
reason to say something on here whereas
in real life you can't just
dive into something like that but for me
i don't even think i've told you i
haven't told you this
i suffer from the most sporadic and
acute
bouts of depression that i cannot even
understand
okay it happens about one day every two
to three months
okay and for that day for that 24 hours
i will be more depressed than i can bear
really
i don't tell anyone about it i will cry
for no reason
but not even like sob but just like
you know like fake movie tears yeah you
can feel it in here
my chest is collapsing yeah and i don't
have
a single clue why you couldn't ask me a
thousand times what's wrong and i won't
be able to tell you why i've
i just i'm so sad that it's unbearable
like i want my world to end i literally
want the world to swallow me up
for no [ __ ] reason wow nothing can
make me happy
you could tell we just hit like a
million subscribers on here and
on that day it won't make me happy
nothing can make me happy on that day
oh wow nothing every couple of months
one day the whole day i will be
unbearably sad do you message anyone
like because obviously we speak almost
every day so i'm asking like i don't
talk to anyone about it
no not talk to anyone about it but do
you actually converse and like
be try and be yourself try and be normal
yeah yeah i
i don't like like we've definitely
spoken on those days
okay and i won't ever act any different
like maybe my responses would be
less enthusiastic than usually might but
not enough for you to really pick up on
okay and i would just act as normal as
humanly possible okay
but i will be so sad so sad like it
happened to me like two weeks ago
okay and they got too much that i cried
really
i had a tear
and then bro just watching tv and i was
like
and then there's like one thing here
just it a quick wipe i'm scared i'm
watching tv
fam you go to sleep i wake up fine fine
completely fine it's so annoying
it's the most inconvenient thing ever
but it doesn't happen
frequently enough for me to ever think
about doing anything about it
because i can't predict it nothing
triggers it as far as i know
something obviously triggers it that you
don't know about but i feel like it's
it's a humbling experience
because i can't remember the last time i
cried
i've not cried in probably a decade and
a half bro
or longer and when i say that to people
they feel like i'm a [ __ ]
heartless heartless [ __ ] but i it's not
like i don't want to cry or i don't
choose
i just fam i have no reason there's been
times where i've been so sad like
obviously these
weird days are beside where i
wish i could cry why i wish i could cry
because i'm just like it would help make
me feel better i know
i remember from crying from experience
before that when you actually just let
it out yeah you feel so much
you feel way better afterwards but i
feel like i can't cry
like obviously this thing with this tear
like that wasn't even enough like
i couldn't ball out like i wanted to it
just i just can't cry yeah i just can't
cry
and um but anyway yeah those weird days
are weird um
i don't want i don't know what triggers
it that's why every few but i
the way i usually chop i know this is
[ __ ] [ __ ] but i the way i chop it
up is because i'm so happy and
enthusiastic all the time
my it's like my in my head i convinced
myself that it's my mind telling me that
i
this is my payback you know what i mean
it's a reality check this is like
you've burned up all your good [ __ ] for
for two months now
like here's some sad [ __ ] like i don't
know obviously that doesn't make sense
it's a relapse kind of thing no
it does make sense it does make sense to
me anyway it does make sense
because you know me yeah i'm always up
yeah my voice notes must be exhausting
for you
they sweep me i'm always up yeah so yeah
when i come down
like i come down but like i said i don't
know what makes me
nothing necessarily triggers me i can't
ever trace something that happens so i'm
just like oh my god maybe you're just
always high on life
like in general because and i think how
long has this been happening for
a couple years hmm has it
been more frequent recently or is it
still been the same way
two three four two months just bang
and i can barely ever remember the last
time it happened that's how far away it
is
the few and far between yeah like i can
remember it happened in the other day
the other week but next time it happens
i probably won't even remember
the last time it happened it's weird i
don't know
i don't know um yeah man i guess it's a
kind of dark way to wrap up the podcast
for [ __ ] one year anniversary but i
don't think this i don't think it's
necessarily dark in the slightest i feel
like
i'm hoping to feel like people got in
touch with themselves listen to us today
do you know what i mean though because
obviously are there are times we
like let's say 85 of the time we just
chat [ __ ] and make people laugh
but that 15 we tap into a different side
of ourselves
and people like it yeah so for some
reason they do
um it's good [ __ ] man and so yeah
guys to wrap it up we love you we
appreciate you
always um and you're helping our dreams
come true
and here's to another year here is to
another year i hope you guys are wearing
your [ __ ]
party hats you got balloons in the
background and everything happy
birthday happy birthday we want some
birthday messages after you see this i'm
expecting bare birthday their birthday
messages
dm me galore diamond my paypal is open
send me my christmas money all right
bless
i love you guys peace